any indication about how the caregivers
in Dallas the nurse that we heard about
earlier and now the second worker might
have contracted the disease they're
certainly still investigating but what
are people saying the CDC is saying
there is an ongoing investigation into
this however quite a few experts in this
field in terms of contamination experts
they're saying that the chances are that
it's something to do with the way that
the protective gear people wearing being
um taken off has been crucial and
there's little details this lady in
Australia was talking about this um that
essentially you take one glove off with
one hand and then you have to use a bare
finger to hook the other gloves and that
things like that may have been a point
of contact that's the kind of thing
they're going to be looking into so okay
so if a new case does crop up once again
in the US somewhere else and we hope
that that doesn't happen What
preparations are being made to prepare
uh to care for that potential patient I
mean people have had time to see the
worst practices and the best practices
right I mean you mentioned there the
sort of shock team of troops that the
CDC will be sending in around the
country they also talked yesterday in
their their press conference Tom frieden
talking about the fact that there'll be
about um 50 different hospitals each
state will have a designated hospital
however some epidemiologists saying this
could be a concern because if a patient
walks into Hospital a and is then told
you're going to be transported to
hospital B that's going to be yet
another possibility of transmission so
that's something they're looking at as
well is is the CDC actually coordinating
all this or or or are hospitals and
States acting kind of ad hoc well we we
reached out to I think the 50 top
earning hospitals yesterday to try and
get responses what is their level of
preparedness and uh all of them that did
get back to us and that was very few I
should add said that obviously they're
coordinating very closely with the CDC
on this and State Health officials so
it's it's it's seemingly quite ad hoc I
think that after yesterday's new
guidelines were issued that will be
something that they'll all be trying to
implement uniformly do you get the sense
as you talk to these hospitals around
the country that there's a sense of
disbelief in other words well what
happened in Dallas couldn't possibly
happen here in Indiana uh no I think the
professionals I spoke to yesterday did
say that there are smaller hospitals
that are not prepared to deal with these
kinds of things and and Dallas presan
Maybe one of those I think that the
larger research focused places like
Emory we've seen where they've been
successfully able to treat Ebola are
much more prepared for this kind of
outbreak but you know the thousands of
hospitals around the United States many
of them far too small without the
experience I tell you what scares me um
um Scarlet again not to be alarmist but
uh we're out a vaccine and galaxo says
while it we'll have 20,000 uh vaccines
available they won't be till December so
that's you know 8 nine weeks away and of
course vaccines wouldn't help anyone
who's infected already I mean now you're
just dealing with experimental treat
it's going to be an expensive process
whatever I mean all of these these
hospitals we reached out to they're
going to have a huge impact on their
bottom lines just in terms of the way
that you treat these patients it's a
very expensive process um the vaccine is
part of that Helma Croft of RBC Capital
markets you just returned to work after
uh changing jobs you've not only walked
into a sell-off on oil prices but also
the Ebola virus situation getting worse
and worse does this come up at all in
your conversations with clients well you
know it does in terms of potentially
Emerging Market stories and I I
highlighted Nigeria before for in terms
of a country at risk I mean Nigeria was
very lucky it's Africa's most populous
country it is a great Emerging Market
story that people like to talk about
they were very lucky that they were able
to contain Ebola I would look at a
country like that and say if you get
into a situation there that could a huge
ramifications for investors you uh
famously made a name for yourself at the
CIA as a risk analyst and that's what
ultimately took you to uh Wall Street
can you quantify it um and may maybe
this is unfair but quantify Ebola as a
risk
to financial markets is that a fair jump
well I think people have been looking at
what it could be shaving off in terms of
African economies and so to me I think
at right now I'm most interested in what
it means as an em story right now again
I would look at countries like Nigeria
where everyone was so focused on as
being this engine of African growth
again they were lucky but if you get a
second wave of this there then you could
really have problems and you could
really sort of derail that story
investors are not going to want to go
live in Legos if you have an Eola break
yeah that's a good point all right vill
marks thank you so much for sharing us
uh the details of your findings on on
this second case of an niola worker a
healthcare worker who has contracted
Ebola